bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors la
situation en californie est ce que c'est
un choc
justement pour les habitants de cet état
oui ils ont commencé l'année avec un
excédent budgétaire des milliards de
dollars 6 milliards de prêts c'est une
provision et donc ils ont pensé des
dépenses est ce les soins médicaux sont
les immigrés est légal et tout était
anéantie gaga nous a dit c'est dans un
clando et le prospectives ont changé et
maintenant c'est les gros coups bougies
tel dramatique 6 milliards de coupes
budgétaires pour 54 milliards de déficit
donc ça mais n'équilibrera pas dans une
année c'est un plan pluriannuel ils vont
commencer au mois de juillet avec un
coût pour tous les employés d'étape de
10 % de leur salaire
après c'est les coupes des soins
médicaux aux immigrés les coupes baltard
dans une grande lande d'année les soins
d'un travail tout le monde et aussi les
universités de californie ont aussi subi
un coup de 10%
c'était non même si une super partie va
être allégé aller de fédérale
alors on va parler justement de l'aide
que peut faire dans la halle trump pour
aider justement cet état qui est
important aux états unis à sortir
justement de ce marasme économique
oui jusqu'au présent la plupart de
l'aide fédérale était donnée au secteur
privé aux entreprises grandes et petites
au salaire pour la seconde chômage mais
souvent moins de 10 % toutes les aides
fédérales est dirigé
les étapes et les états comme vous avez
aux états unis pour la plus grande
partie des charges pour le secours
médical est donc maintenant les
démocrates qui contrôlent la chambre de
représentants propose législation pour
donner trois millions de dans leur jeu
précises à ces trois mille milliards de
dollars
un nouvel plan de sauvetage hibernent
billions de cela est dédié aux étapes
mais la maison blanche on essaie de
faire un veto sur ces législations pour
des raisons strictement économique
alors pour qu'on comprenne bien que pèse
l'état de californie sur l'économie
américaine oh oui on dit que si c'était
un pays indépendant serait prise à la
neuville plus grande économie du monde
s'est uni non partie de moteurs de
croissance dans l'économie américain
avec le silicon valley et les gares a
les grandes sociétés d internet mais en
plus c'est un peu comme le craindre
aussi ça veut dire que un grosse
majorité de légumes et de fruits frais
aux états unis est produit dans
californie et là c'est un secteur qui
sous le choc
à cause d'eux le continent'' alors on
imagine que c'est ce qui va se passer
dans les mois à venir en californie la
manière dont la crise va être gérée
crise économique ré sanitaires ça va
jouer aussi en vue de la présidentielle
qui est prévu donc à l'automne prochain
aux états unis
oui exactement parce qu'en novembre dans
l'eau tran se présente contre joe biden
mais aussi toutes les représentantes
aussi ceux présents dans cette élection
et les sénateurs
des saynètes aussi joue dans cette
élection est maintenant le seul a dirigé
par nicole neveu a donné un plan de
sauvetage aux états bleus ça veut dire
aux états comme californie qui sont
dirigées par le parti opposant
démocratique et donc il y a maintenant
les frênes seul est de donner aux éclats
comme les têtes contrôlée par garde nous
mais qui est un démocrate donc une
opposante et a joué et le pronostic avec
l'aide des états pourrait causer un
arrêt récent croissance de la pandémie
parce que ce sont les écrits nommant qui
contrôle ou lâcher le contrôle sur la
croissance de pandémie aux états unis
merci beaucoup
douglas y est d'avoir répondu en direct
à nos questions sur arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
droit et spécialiste de sciences
politiques américaines merci à vous